haben sie auch einen tick müssen sie
drei mal kontrollieren ob sie die
haustür wirklich abgeschlossen haben
oder fühlen sich insgeheim vom nachbarn
beobachtet oder können keinen wein im
keller holen aus angst vor einer spinne
dann willkommen im club denn ein
bisschen verrückt sind hier alle glauben
die sigmund freud hat das zu tun mit der
architektur unserer psyche heute warten
die uns vor in dieses komplexe bauwerk
und zwar an der hand von peter schneider
er ist psychoanalytiker hochschuldozent
und cologne ist und ich freue mich sehr
dass er hier ist herzlich willkommen
für mich doch herr schneider sie haben
sich selber einmal im jahr ein interview
als ex zwangsneurotiker mit einem hahn
dienst depressiver gezeichnet haben sie
sich selber analysiert immer wieder mal
versucht aber das bringt ja meistens
nichts wenn man ganz wenn uns ganz
alleine macht also ich habe eben auch
eine analyse absolviert das hat geholfen
erstaunlicherweise weil
zwangsneurotische gelten eigentlich als
sehr hartnäckige fälle die sich das bei
ihm auch furchtbar also ich hab listen
und eine agenda die sozusagen jeder tag
war irgendwie so ein vlies telegramm
wenn dann und keine ahnung ich habe
schon nichts geschrieben mehr weil ich
so zwanghaft akzeptiert habe also dass
das war wirklich wirklich schlimm und
jetzt zeigt sich eher umgekehrt also
jetzt habe ich eher so eine art von von
gewisser schlampigkeit bei der ich dann
aber immer befürchtet dass sie dann wenn
sie zu sehr unter druck gerät wird ein
zwanghafter umschlägt und dieses spiel
sozusagen zwischen den anteil in unserer
psyche oder auch seele
das ist ja etwas was wir alle haben die
alle haben neurotische teile hysterische
teile manchmal aggressive teile
das zumindest ist auch die theorie von
sigmund freud heißt das auch dass wir
uns alle eine psychoanalyse hilfreich
wäre
ich glaube da habe ich inzwischen auch
eine andere auffassung dazu also in der
zeit dann habe ich mir gedacht das wär
sicher dass
heilmittel für alle und alles aber ich
glaub man muss auch ein bestimmtes
interesse haben was normalerweise eben
dann der leidensdruck ist wenn man jetzt
so es ist einfach nur so just for fun
das kann man machen oder vielleicht gibt
es besondere personen bei denen das
leichter geht als bei anderen
aber ich hätte zum beispiel mal eine
kurzzeit patientin bei der wirklich nix
nix zu holen war und nichts zu bringen
und wir haben es dann wirklich nach zehn
stunden im einverständnis aufgelöst
so kamen sie zu ihnen es ist etwas
kompliziert man man kann also auch aus
anderen therapierichtungen sozusagen so
eine art fremd ja bei einem
psychoanalytiker machen das war es ein
verhaltenstherapeutin die die das
einfach mal ausprobieren wollte
und es gab eine andere bei der hat das
hervorragend funktioniert und bei der
die hatte einfach wirklich wie man so
schön sagt keine probleme also man hat
wirklich auch gemerkt wie die arme sich
irgendetwas aus den fingern saugen
musste und sie sind ja selber
hochschuldozent sie sind satiriker sie
sind kolumnistin machen ganz viele dinge
aber drei tage die woche nehmen sie sich
die zeit immer noch für patienten und
patientinnen da zu sein
wie viele sind denn im moment ich zähle
die patientin ich zähle immer die
stunden und das sind so zwischen 25 und
30 stunden an den drei tagen
und das heißt es gibt auch patienten die
zwei stunden bleiben oder was heißt dass
sein nein eigentlich nicht
also eben die analyse ist heutzutage
meistens dreistündige zu meiner zeit war
es vier und fünf ständig also das hat
sich einfach im laufe der zeit geändert
und manche kommen halt jeden tag wenn
jemand von ganz weit weg kommt das habe
ich ab und zu auch mal gehabt da macht
man vielleicht eine doppelstunde aber
sonst doch einfach mal einer nach dem
anderen
den tag die kommen nicht jeden tag zu
ihnen von montag bis mittwoch drei tage
hintereinander sorgen sich bei ihnen hin
das ist also ganz schlimm liegt genau
liegt das ist ein gutes stichwort also
aufwendig ist die sache schon mal und
beim liegen wenn ihr beim liegen sind
wir natürlich auch bei der couch und die
couch ist ja sowas wie das sinnbild
geworden für die psychoanalyse
sie haben ja eine kolumne ganz wunderbar
geschrieben psychoanalyse sei dermaßen
eigentlich unaufgeregt dass man das
setting mystifizierung müsste wie ist es
denn bei ihnen machen sie sitzend oder
liegend
beides so eben da mache ich kein theater
aus ich find couch hat gewisse vorteile
bei manchen patienten die dann einfach
freier sagen ohne mich anzuschauen
sondern das blaue sprechen können manche
patientin stört das halt mehr die können
sich dann auch setzen also ich würde in
dem sinne wirklich die couch
entmystifizieren aber es ist natürlich
interessant wie sie so zum zur ikone der
psychoanalyse geworden ist und das hängt
zunächst natürlich mit der herkunft aus
der aus der hypnose technik zusammen
also die freud und breuer angewandt
haben und 1895 in studien über history
beschrieben haben und seither hat eben
die couch so eine ikonografische
bedeutung oder sie ist auch das was sein
return mal aktiv abdeckt genannt hat
oder ein objekt mit dem wir denken also
es gibt sicher psychoanalytiker oder gar
psychoanalytiker die vielleicht
niemanden haben der sich auf die couch
legt aber zur praxis gehört dennoch die
couch und selbst in veröffentlichungen
wo es gar nicht in psychoanalyse geht es
um allgemeine psychologie gibt es oft
irgendwie eine abbildung der couch oder
sogar noch irgendwie
freud hinter der couch obwohl es
überhaupt nicht um psychoanalyse geht
und was genau gemacht wird wenn da
jemand auf der couch liegt darüber
sprechen wir nachher gleich zuerst
gucken wir uns dieses so fahren denn das
sofa oder die couch von 7 und freut die
gibt es tatsächlich immer noch und steht
in london
in diesem schmucken haus im londoner
hampstead quartier steht es das
berühmteste sofa der weltgeschichte
sigmund freuds couch das symbol der
psychoanalyse hier empfing der
weltberühmte denker bis kurz vor seinem
tod noch patienten in einem
arbeitszimmer welches er haargenau
eingerichtet hatte wie jenes in wien
1938 als 82 jähriger hatte freud seine
heimat verlassen müssen
vertrieben von den nazis sein ruf als
skandalumwitterter seelendoktor eilte
freut damals voraus die presse war
ziemlich feindselig ihm gegenüber er sei
ein mann voller komische ideen und
dessen vom thema sex er sei sogar nicht
britisch ließ es aber man zeigte auch
respekt vor ihm
er hatte stets hochkarätige gäste als
virginia woolf oder salvador dalí kamen
zu besuch
freuds psychoanalyse als behandlung
seelischer probleme seine theorien zum
unbewussten
sie sind bis heute umstritten was bleibt
von ihm er war revolutionieren mit
seinen ideen seinen schriften er hatte
sehr großen einfluss darauf wie die
menschen in 20 und 21 jahrhundert er
sich selber denken
1939 verstirbt der schwerkranke freud an
einer von ihm selbst bestimmten über
dosis morphin seine letzte wohn und
wirkungsstätte ist heute ein museum
herr schneider in diesem museum waren
sie auch schon sie haben wenn ich
richtig informiert bin auch mit der
haushälterin von freude noch tee
getrunken
das haben sie noch aus naja ich war da
als es eben noch kein museum war also
1982 glaube ich das war ein jahre zwei
jahre bevor an erfreut gestorben seine
tochter ja und das war eben das da war
normales business is used in dem haus
also es war die haushälterin da es kam
dann noch jeden irgend ein zweiter
haushälterin war paula fichtel war da
auch schon glaube ich in 80ern
wahrscheinlich ja und dann hab ich da in
diesen haben dem sicht auf die couch
gelegt nehme ich habe mich nicht getraut
es wäre überhaupt kein problem gewesen
also ich war den ganzen tag alleine in
dem in dem arbeiten zimmer und habe mir
die bücher angeschaut weil ich da was
recherchieren wollte zum problem der
katharsis und um die tamilen im beitrag
gehört dass die presse nicht nur
begeistert war sondern zum teil auch
feindseliges das ist ein mann mit
komischen ideen der sei von sex besessen
gewesen
peter schneider hand aufs herz ein
bisschen stimmt das ja schon oder nein
also ich glaube die feindseligkeit
gegenüber freut wird auch immer gerne
von der psychoanalyse überbetont also um
diesen revolutionären charakter der
psychoanalyse zu betreuen
also wenn man sich zb der traumdeutung
früher rezensionen anschaut die sind
durchaus sehr wohlwollend natürlich gibt
es oder gab es erbitterte feinde der
psychoanalyse wie der psychiater hofft
freiburger psychiater aber es war nicht
so wie freut es auch gerne stilisiert
hat dass er nur gegen widerstände
anzukämpfen hatte ich meine jetzt
lustigerweise gar nicht ob es stimmt
dass er feinde gehabt hat sondern ob er
besessen von sechs gelaufen ist ja
besessen würde ich das jetzt eben auch
nicht nennen also dass er sich mit der
sexualität beschäftigt ex also explizit
in einem werk das ist 1905 da kann man
sagen da seine sexual theorie hat einen
wichtigen wichtigen position in seiner
theorie gefördert dass dieses
verständnis natürlich dafür dadurch mit
dieser unseligen symbolen theorie wo
dann eben alle symbole oder fast alle
symbole sexueller natur sind was aber
eben auch ein einen ein motiv hat das
mit dem sex gar nicht so viel zu tun hat
sondern mit seinem versuch aus dem doch
sehr biografischen individuellen zu so
etwas wie generalisierten aussagen über
das psychische zu kommen und diese
generalisierung sind halt laufen dann
über sexuelle aber müssen vielleicht ein
bisschen dingfest machen zb der ödipus
komplex das ist ja die idee dass dann
das kind zum alter zwischen drei und
fünf jahren eine phase hat wo es sich
hingezogen fühlt zu vater oder mutter
jeweils zum gegen geschlechtlichen und
dadurch in rivalität tritt zum
gleichgeschlechtlichen also je nachdem
zu vater oder mutter und daraus wird
dann ganz viel erklärt bis hin zu dass
frau ja auch die idee hatte dass viele
störungen die wir haben
die ungleichgewichte in uns zu tun haben
mit der unterdrückung des sexualtriebs
jetzt um das ein bisschen besser zu
verstehen wenn ich noch mal ein beispiel
nehmen des eingangs seiner anmoderation
wenn ich den zwang habe zehn mal
kontrollieren zu müssen ob die tür jetzt
verschlossen ist was hat etwas zu tun
mit einem unterdrückten sexualtrieb das
müssen sie mir erklären ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich das erklären kann weil ich
das eben so auch nicht glaube nehmen sie
an
also es ist mein standard beispiel wer
mich kennt kennt wahrscheinlich auch das
beispiel darum nicht kenne mich nicht so
viele nehmen wir das mal an dass sie da
immer an der tür herum machen muss das
wäre okay wenn also man könnte es
irgendwie ödipale von mir aus bedeuten
wenn der vater handelsvertreter gewesen
wäre und das über die assoziation des
klinkenputzen es läuft nicht dann hätte
das eine individuelle geschichte in sich
aus der man was machen kann
nun gibt es aber auch ganz viele leute
mit flugangst mit der angst vor spinnen
wo man eben individuell eigentlich
schaltet also man kann da keiner sagt
was fällt ihnen denn dann ein zu der
spinne
man kann da nicht erzählen die musen
nahmen sie vor spinnen ins bett gelegt
und bin ja das ist ja das kommt die
angeworfen sodann magen darm grippe oder
das etwa so also unspezifisch oder mein
vater hat immer gesagt du spinnst und
kalkulieren nein es wird ja häufig über
solche über solche absurden vermeintlich
absurden assoziationen wenn es läuft
aber manchmal läuft es eben nicht und
das war dann der kniff jetzt kommt das
mit der sexualisierung und den symbolen
irgendwann hat freut ja auch gemerkt
dass es sozusagen symptome gibt die
keine geschichte erzählen das war seine
erste theorie jedes symptom erzählt
eigentlich eine geschichte wenn man es
richtig versteht
und dann ist ihm ein ein
sprachwissenschaftler zu hilfe gekommen
der die theorie hatte die sprache sei
deshalb entstanden weil die urmenschen
sich arbeit durch sexuelle begriffe
angenehm gemacht hätten
also die ursprünge der sprache waren
darin so zu sagen wir gehen mal mutter
erde vögeln
das war dann der arzt drückt sozusagen
fürs finden und freuds idee
es gibt so etwas wie eine uhr sprache
die eben aus diesem grunde immer sexuell
sein muss und also gibt es auch symptome
die mir nicht mehr individuell verstehen
kann oder muss sondern die man im
rückgriff auf diese ursprüngliche
sprache verstehen muss und dann ist klar
warum das was er am anfang in der
traumdeutung sagt ist man kann alles im
traum auch symbolisierung nur
individuell verstehen hat dann diese
fixe sexuelle bedeutung bekommen und das
ist glaube ich einer der sündenfälle der
psychoanalyse und eine schwierigkeit ist
ja auch es gibt bei freud
dieses moment wo er auch eben sagt wir
müssen das was die leute erzählen
vielleicht auch nicht immer für bare
münze nehmen es gibt diese phase in der
er diese vielen patientinnen die an
hysterie gelitten habe er festgestellt
hatte erzählen alle davon dass der vater
sie missbraucht hätte und er hat das für
bare münze genommen und irgendwann
gesagt nein das ist eben eine geschichte
die an so symbolen anknüpft und das
heißt nicht dass die tatsächlich
missbraucht worden sind
es ist meine frage wie weiß wann denn
aus analytiker ob man sich eine
geschichte sozusagen ausgedacht hat sich
etwas zu recht vernünftig sage ich jetzt
mal oder ob das einfach dieser struktur
der menschlichen psyche entstammt und
mehr an so eben dingen anknüpft die
symbolischer natur sind ja also ich muss
ehrlich sagen die frage hat sich mir so
noch nie gestellt
und doch in 30 jahren praxis also wenn
jemand von von einem tatsächlich
stattgefundene missbrauch erzählt dann
ist das einfach was anderes als wenn dir
jemand sexuelle fantasien und ehrlich
gesagt auch sexuelle fantasien mit dem
vater sind jetzt eher selten
also ich glaube da hat freut um um etwas
neues erfinden zu können wahrscheinlich
auch übertrieben also ich denke was er
seine seine seine erfindung war ist dass
es eine psychische realität gibt eine
inner psychische realität die genau so
wirkungsmächtig ist wie die äußere
realität und ich schätze da hatte dann
auch ein bisschen geschummelt mit dem
vielleicht um dieses diese realität
sozusagen ein vollständiges bild zu
bekommen hilft eigentlich dieses eisberg
modell war sehr oft genommen wird
nämlich diese vorstellung dass unser ich
über bewusste teile und über
unterbewusste teile verfügt es gibt aber
nicht nur das ich sondern es gibt eben
auch das über ich und das ist das
über-ich besteht vor allem in regeln in
der moral in verboten geboten in dem was
wir tun sollen und dass es eben im
lustprinzip in diesen trieben auch in
diesen sexuellen vorstellungen und
fantasien ist denn dass ich das was ich
bin sozusagen dauernd aufgerieben
zwischen über ich und es und gar nicht
wirklich herr oder herr im eigenen haus
das ist freut behauptung dass oder dass
ich sei irgend wie der dumme august der
immer so tun müssen als wenn das was
schief ging in seiner absicht lege und
hier ist es ja nicht einfach nur das
dass es sich durch spezifische gewicht
unter irgendetwas hält sondern wenn man
schon auf dieses modell zurückgreifen
will dass es da ständige konflikte gibt
und eben auch zb prozesse der
verdrängung
die verdrängung zeigt man es zeigt sich
da allerdings wiederum gut also eben in
dem das wird man ja dann drängt als
verdrängt bezeichnen das gleichzeitig
wiederum etwas anderes hervor bringt und
wenn man sich nun also in einer
psychoanalyse heute begibt dann geht es
eben darum zu versuchen teile von diesem
unbewussten ebene sichtbar zu machen
indem man erzählt in dem man spricht
dann werden einem dinge bewusst man
erzählt auch träume
das stellt man sich relativ gemütlich
vormann liegt bei herrn schneider in der
praxis und redet ein bisschen und fertig
ist aber diejenigen die eine
psychoanalyse machen erzählen meistens
davon dass das wahnsinnig anstrengend
sei warum eigentlich
ja ich war also ich glaube so wie ich
das mache ich weiß nicht ob sie da viele
finden würden die das jetzt als
besonders anstrengend bezeichnen würden
das gibt natürlich immer wieder also das
gibt es wenn etwas sehr scham behaftet
ist über das man über das man spricht
aber sagen wir mal
business as usual ist tatsächlich glaube
ich eher eine gewisse gemütlichkeit also
eine gewisse entspannung für die dann
auch die couch steht dies ein möglich
macht relativ eben relativ frei zu
assoziieren die freie assoziation ist
natürlich auch ein konstrukt weil man
geht davon aus dass diese freiheit
gerade durch abkömmlinge des unbewussten
dann wiederum in ein durch das
unbewusste wiederum die terminiert ist
ich glaube das anstrengende kommt er aus
diesem begriff des widerstandes
also freut sagt ja dass da wo die
analytische arbeit stockt dann muss ein
widerstand gegen die entdeckung von
etwas unbewussten dasein und der
widerstand ist sozusagen auf seiten
dieser beziehung analysen
psychoanalytikerin das was ihnen
psychisch die abwehr ist
und ich glaube da kommt auch dadurch
dass man sich diese metapher auch zu
eigen macht sagen manche leute
vielleicht ja es ist anstrengend es ist
wie arbeit man muss eben da diesen
widerstand überwinden
aber ich glaube das ist mehr eine
metaphern induzierte wahrnehmung oder
redeweise die nicht unbedingt so der
praxis entspricht
nun wenn ich irgendwann wenn ich ja in
so einer psychoanalyse bin verstehe
warum ich immer kontrollieren muss warum
ob die tiere jetzt abgeschlossen ist
oder warum ich angst habe vor spinnen
heißt das ja noch nicht dass ich
deswegen tatsächlich in den keller gehen
kann und wein holen und die
verhaltenstherapie die geht ja anders
vor die würde ja sagen es spielt gar
keine rolle warum ich mich fürchte vor
spinnen und es spielt auch keine rolle
ob ich ein sehe das spinnen gefährlich
sind oder nicht es geht ganz alleine
darum mit dieser angst zu leben die
irgendwie zu händeln und wenn das darin
bestehen würde dass ich mich vorher
verkleiden muss ja dann sagt leide ich
mich vorher hauptsache ich kann nachher
den wein holen
jemand hat auf instagram gefragt warum
peter schneider sind sie nicht verhallt
ist therapeut geworden das doch
eigentlich der einfachere weg vielleicht
mit psychischen leiden umzugehen
also ich glaube so einfach ist es eben
auch nicht und das haben auch die
verhaltenstherapeuten über die zeit mit
bekommen also so einfach lässt sich
zeugs auch nicht antrainieren oder
abtrainieren und die verhaltenstherapie
hat ja auch eine große entwicklung
mitgemacht aber ich würde auch sagen
also wenn jemand einfach angst vor
spinnen hat würde ich dann gehen sie in
den so machen sie das gibt es ja so
spinnen spinnen kurs positions- der iran
und das ist auch noch irgendwie hat sich
mal wenn man sich die viecher genau
anguckt sind die wirklich wirklich
putzig ja oder ich hab meine insekten
ekel den ich auch us studie haben ja
viele kinder und so habe ich gedämpft
dadurch dass ich all den viechern namen
gebe also das ist dann die spinne
klaus-dieter und so und kleinere kann
ich deshalb schon gut anfassen
das ist ein interessanter trick das was
einem angst macht benennen das können
wir vielleicht mal mitnehmen ja glaub
ich noch schnell eben das zur
innensanierung verhaltenstherapie ist
dann auch gut und ich glaube das macht
man auch in der psychoanalyse dass man
sagt ja entweder fragen sie jemand
anderen den wein drauf zu holen oder sie
reißen sich zusammen und gehen doch wo
es nur eben anders ist also wo man dann
spezifisch auch noch psychoanalytisch
was entdecken kann ist eben wenn der
vater alkoholiker war und die tochter
immer den wein aus dem keller holen dann
hat es diese dann hat es diese
geschichte aber ob die spinne in der
ursprache für den penis stand und sonst
also sicher nicht lächerlich machen
es gibt ja eine ganze reihe von von
begriffen die auch schon wieder
ebenfalls zu ikonen geworden sind also
denken die an sublimation zb penisneid
ödipus komplex kenly alles es gibt eine
schöne sammlung von diesen verschiedenen
begriffen von der school of life und ein
solcher zentrale begriff ist das trauma
und die idee ist ja wirklich dass wir
alle schon ein geburtstag haben dass sie
unter dem wir nachher irgendwie leiden
und die traumata in unserem leben sind
eigentlich das was wir auch beheben
müssten irgendwie in einer art und weise
was hat es mit diesem trauma auf sich
auch das ist wieder furchtbar komplett
ich glaube dass fußball die flex und
analytisch komplette historie ist
komplex und systematisch komplex also
was freud oder was wir freut verdanken
glaube ich ist die idee eines inneren
traumas das ist aber ganz am anfang der
psychoanalyse viele würden sagen das ist
noch vor analytisch also eben die
history analyse 18 95 im zusammenhang
mit der hypnose da geht darum dass so
ein effekt der nicht genügend abgeführt
werden konnte oder ein verdrängter
gedanke dass der von ihnen dramatisch
wirkt
nicht also man könnte fast sagen das ist
so wie wenn man auf irgendeiner rache
sitzen geblieben ist das vergessen hat
aber das wirkt von innen noch noch
dramatisch und dann ist der gedanke von
freud und und breuer und der hypnose
reproduzieren wir diese situation und
der effekt kann abgeführt werden
es ist ein bisschen wie dr pimpl popper
etwas komplexer sdr pinkl puppe es die
vulgäre populäre allgemeinbildung das
ist dieser hautärztin auf irgendeinem
komischen sender die immer ständig
irgendwelche lieb ohne aufschneidet und
ausdrückt es ist faszinierend gruß und
so vielleicht gönnt man sich das könnte
man sich das eben die dieser abfuhr auch
vorstellen also indem man es ausspricht
wird der effekt abgefüllt das modell ist
sein dass reflex modell was irgendwie
also reiz reinkommt muss wieder
abgeführt werden und die hysterie die
verdrängung verhindert das und das
machen wir jetzt dann also das ist
glaube ich tatsächlich eine wichtige
erkenntnis die dann aber auch eben die
psychoanalyse hat ja nicht aufgebaut
dann auf den studien über history
sondern dass die offizielle
geschichtsschreibung fängt gewissermaßen
mit der traumdeutung an und da würde ich
glaube ich auch die kontinuität
vielleicht etwas stärker betonen als es
die psychoanalyse häufig in ihrer
selbstdarstellung gemacht wird das ist
ja sowieso etwas was ihnen sehr wichtig
ist immer wieder auch zu sagen man muss
diese texte von freud das was er
geschrieben habe irgendwie auch
historisieren man muss sie sehen im
historischen kontext auch im kontext
dessen was er alles geschrieben hat und
nicht so häppchenweise rausnehmen so wie
man auch bei kant allerhand dinge findet
die man heute abstoßend findet kann man
dennoch aus den ideen von kant etwas
gewinnen sie sagen an einer stelle auch
in ihrem neuesten buch normal gestört
verrückt über das wir nachher gleich
sprechen dass sie eigentlich wie ein
ethnographische antreten
diese schriften von 7 und freut auch als
hochschuldozent unter anderem in berlin
an einer universität in der es um die
geschichte der psychoanalyse geht tun
sie genau dass sie versuchen also die
psychoanalyse nicht einfach eins zu eins
anzuwenden sondern historisch zu sehen
ja ich glaube das ist so das ist auch
eine persönliche entwicklung von mir ich
glaube oder ich rede jetzt nur familie
irgendwann gab es einfach dieses
missbehagen an dem immer kleinteiligeren
freut philologischen und das habe ich
lange zeit auch gemacht und auch immer
versucht noch mehr sagen aus den
schriften rauszuholen
das hat seinen eigenen charme also
sozusagen die psychoanalyse nochmal zu
psycho analysieren
aber es hat auch eben seine grenzen also
man bewegt sich dann immer in diesem in
diesem selben kosmos und für mich war
dann irgendwie ein ausweg was dich das
hat vor zehn jahren vielleicht begonnen
dieses interesse an der science of
science also wissenschaft studien ludwig
fleck zb aus den 30er jahren noch also
sozusagen der der der urvater dieser art
von von betrachtungsweise mit seinem
buch entstehung und entwicklung einer
wissenschaftlichen tatsache dass es dann
für mich immer wichtiger geworden und
jetzt ist irgendwie für mich mehr die
frage also wenn ich mich theoretisch mit
psychoanalyse entwickeln eben wie kommt
freut auf so eine eigentlich absurde
idee mit dem ödipus komplex dem
kastrations- der kastration angst und
dem penisneid oder eben sublimation also
wie kommt man oder wozu dient dieser
begriff wenn man vorher immer von einem
gegensatz von kultur und triebhaftigkeit
geräten ist ja vielleicht kurz klären
sowie die nation spricht dann später
beim philosophen lacken eine ganz große
rolle also die idee dass wir sozusagen
weil gewisse dinge verboten sind
überschuss handlungen machen er sagt zum
beispiel es gibt immer besonders schön
das lieder und liebesgedichte in einer
kultur in der sexualität verboten ist
dass es sozusagen die idee der
sublimation und daneben auch die
grundlage für viel kulturelles geschehen
ja und das ist dann wiederum tritt man
kann das ja richtig oder oder oder auch
in manchen bezweifle haft bezweifelt
wert finden
das ist dann zum beispiel eine idee wie
man diesen gegensatz von kultur und
trieb nicht auflösen kann aber anders
anders denken zum beispiel und wie sie
gesagt haben mit kant also man kann sich
wahrscheinlich leicht ob das kann man
sicher nicht sich affirmativ auf kant
berufen wie man sich auf einen in der
physik auf einen vor allem halben jahr
veröffentlichten aufsatz berufen kann wo
man irgendwie dass man irgendeinen teil
hat man neu vermessen und dass das ist
wirklich etwas anderes auch in der zeit
sozusagen sehen
trotzdem wurde die wissenschaftlichkeit
der psychoanalyse immer wieder irgendwie
kritisch gesehen man hat das seinem
versucht zu untergraben sie schreiben in
ihrem buch normal gestört verrückt auch
dass es eigentlich parallel zur kritik
zu erstarkenden kritik an der
psychoanalyse ein erstarken gab der
neuropsychiatrie also der vorstellung
dass wir sozusagen alles mit
bildgebenden verfahren im hirn irgendwie
lösen können wir wissen dann passgenau
wo das problem ist und versuchen
passgenau die lösung zu finden
das gab es allerdings auch bereits im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert denken sie zum
beispiel an die lobotomie ein ganz
grausames also brachiales verfahren bei
dem er mit einem spitzen gegenstand
oberhalb des auges in see gestochen hat
und versucht hat nervenbahnen durch zu
trennen um eben menschen wurden
psychischen leiden zu erlösen das sind
ja wirklich grauenhafter verfahren wenn
man daran denkt was hat er eigentlich
freut für eine meinung von solchen
verfahren
wahrscheinlich keine besonders gute also
für ihn war es ja nicht ich hab das mal
die die lokalisation des seelischen
genannt also das war das was er
vorangebracht hat die psyche eben nicht
jetzt irgendeinen ort zuzuweisen sondern
das was das psychische ist also dieser
gegensatz auch von bewussten unbewussten
ganz verschiedenen stellen aufzusuchen
also sei es in der literatur sei es im
traum sei es im witz sei es in
fehlleistung sei es wo also sozusagen
psyche ist überall und das ist jetzt auf
irgendeine art wieder eine gegenbewegung
also nicht dass das nicht auf nicht auch
schon vorher in irgendwelcher form
gegeben hat aber jetzt gibt es wieder so
zu sagen so eine lokalisierung die auf
skiern zählt und dann gibt es natürlich
andererseits auch wieder so eine
einrichtung im feminismus zum beispiel
bei wilson eine art von psychischen
neuer psychosomatik zu begründen in der
eben auch das ganz das ganze körperliche
eine rolle spielt in body went geschenkt
worden und geschichten genau ich und er
sehe ja was bei freude natürlich dann in
den drei abhandlungen zur sexual theorie
auch schon angelegt ist und trotzdem ist
natürlich dieses verhältnis zwischen
hirn materie auch und psyche man kann
auch sagen seele sind wir schon fast
schon beim leib seele problem etwas was
die gesamte philosophie geschichte und
auch ein stück weit die psychiatrie
durchzieht und trotz dieser grauenhaften
geschichten zum teilen wie
beispielsweise eben die lobotomie ist
man bis heute voller hoffnung durch
eingriff ins gehirn psychisches leiden
zu lindern etwa durch den einsatz von
sogenannten hirnschrittmacher zurzeit
wird daran geforscht ob sich hier ein
schrittmacher auch bei sehr schweren
fällen von depressionen einsetzen lassen
die sf sendung einstein hat eine solche
operation begleitet die patientin litt
jahrzehntelangen depressionen und
vier versuche wir sehen hier bilder der
operation bei welcher der
hirnschrittmacher getestet wird der
patientin wird die schädeldecke geöffnet
dann werden elektroden an bestimmten
stellen platziert um elektrische impulse
abzugeben
die operation erfolgt bei vollem
bewusstsein denn so kann der effekt
unmittelbar geprüft werden
nein auch nicht nein
beck ich so ein leichtes gefühl fühlt
sich gut an
ja und man wann haben sie das letzte
wort gehabt
das ist schon lange her können wir noch
ein bisschen höher
jetzt machen sie auch noch richtig
lustig jetzt immer meine leute fühlen
sich einfach so gut dass jährlich nehmen
gut
also ich kann jetzt aufstehen und gehen
ok bitte nicht ein bisschen aber das
gefühl habe ich gerade so hätten geld so
taten solche verfahren sind natürlich
immer nur ein teil eines großen
maßnahmenpaketes leben auch
psychotherapie und medikamenten
trotzdem haben sie hoffnung auf solche
verfahren oder sind da eher skeptisch
beides eigentlich also ich bin skeptisch
immer mit bezüglich so glücksversprechen
die aber zu jeder neuen methode gehören
nicht also das breite psychoanalyse ich
ja nicht anders gewesen also den 50er
jahren haben die sich hier vorgestellt
sie seien jetzt wirklich die heilmethode
und ich denke so ein verfahren ist
sicherlich theoretisch besser abgestützt
als das logo tommy verfahren nicht also
das war ja das war gar nicht mehr böse
gemeint aber es ist einfach eine völlig
theoretische radikalkur gewesen was man
nur feststellen muss praktisch alle
versprechen haben sich in vielleicht
nicht in luft aufgelöst aber einfach so
in kleinen kleinen also wir haben das
problem
psychopharmaka wirken aber man kann oft
nicht genau sagen wie sie wirken es man
muss sie unspezifisch einsetzen also man
kann auch antipsychotika schlafmittel
geben und es funktioniert nicht ganz
genau so wie in somatischen medizin also
keine heilsversprechen
es gibt ja auch noch eine vielleicht
ganz entscheidende einsicht wenn man
eben von der psychoanalyse herkommt und
das spielt in ihrem buch auch eine große
rolle nämlich das sigmund freud
eigentlich nicht die idee hatte dass es
psychische krankheit im engeren sinne
gibt sondern wir alle leiden eigentlich
unter denselben konflikten krankhaft
wird es nur dann wenn es störend ist um
das ist heute ein bisschen anders also
sie haben eigentlich als anlass dieses
buches das sogenannte dsm 5 genommen
also mein sohn hat ein amerikanischer
juden für psychische erkrankungen und
diese fünfte auflage dieses dsm 5
enthält heute 312 störungen während
dessen die erste auflage von 1952 gerade
mal 60 solche störungen enthalten hat
und sie sagen die explosion am
psychiatrischen diagnosen die ist zum
teil auch kritisch zu sehen nicht nur
aber zum teil warum ja schon sie hat
natürlich sie geht einher mit einer
zunehmenden pathologisierung das kann
man glaube ich so sagen und bringt dann
probleme wie eben dass man einerseits
wirklich eine diagnose stellen will und
dann aber ständig von co mobilität redet
also sein
am schluss haben sie dann statt einer
vernünftigen beschreibung wie in einer
fallgeschichte haben sie daneben 14
verschiedene diagnosen die alle
irgendwie nebeneinander existieren das
einfach unbefriedigend aber dsm 5 war
der versuch eine wirklich biologisch
neurologische ideologie der einzelnen
störung anzugeben also psychologie eine
ursachenforschung ursachenforschung an
die dann auch therapien hätten ansetzen
können und das ist einfach grandios
gescheitert weil es weil es diese
bestimmungen nicht nicht nicht gab es
gibt keine marke mit denen sie eine
zwangsstörung von einer
anpassungsstörung unterscheiden können
es gibt einfach beschriebenen symptome
aber wie sie die gruppieren also es hat
etwas von einer pseudo extra dort dann
gibt's ja auch psychiater die richtig
kritisch sind allen francis zum beispiel
den sie auch zitieren
der hat noch am dsm vier mitgearbeitet
und sich jetzt einer der ganz dem enten
kritiker und er sagt eigentlich ist erst
mit der sozusagen ein feststellung oder
oder dem dem formulieren einer diagnose
er findet man den kranken oder den
patienten jagd da wäre ich dann auch
wieder skeptisch also da bin ich ein
anhänger dessen was ihren hecking den
dynamischen nominal ismus nennt also der
rhein um nominal ismus wer einfach
mitnimmt namen und tut dann so als gäbe
es dann auch auf der anderen seite etwas
was dieser name benennt und dynamische
nominal ismus heißt eben es entsteht da
irgendetwas man muss sich das so als ein
unklares aber sich so ein bisschen
verfestigen das gewusel von von
irgendwas in der gesellschaft im
vorstellen und dann kommt eine
bezeichnung auf dem buch habe ich das
zum beispiel an burnout das burnout hat
macht verschiedene phasen durch also es
ist erst die krankheit der helfenden
berufe und dann fühlen sich aber auch
andere aus anderen berufen mit dem
begriff des burnouts besser beschrieben
als mit der depression zum beispiel und
das geht so hin und her so in einem
zirkulären prozess und auf einmal hat
sich der begriff verfestigt dass man
kann sich darunter vorstellen
und es haben sich auch seien die
individuen die sich darunter verstanden
wissen haben sich auch irgendwie
stabilisiert und ich glaube so muss man
sich das vorstellen also da sitzt nicht
im gremium zusammen und
er findet irgendwas und es kann ja in
beide richtungen eigentlich eine wirkung
haben das erzählen sie auch sehr schön
in diesem buch etwas aus krankheit aus
also mit einer diagnose feststellbare
krankheit zu definieren kann linderung
bringen weil ein leiden plötzlich
wirklich ernst genommen wird es kann
aber auch eine form von herabsetzungen
bedeuten weil etwas was wir vielleicht
auch einfach aus variante sehen könnten
pathologisiert wird also es hat
eigentlich immer diese bewegung in beide
richtungen ja und darum kann man auch
nicht also dass kein anti
psychiatrisches bucht und ich bin also
auch die anti psychiatrie hat ihre
starken negativen seiten schizophrenie
zum beispiel also vom bleuler gegen
kriens dementia praecox also vorzeitige
verblödung das war ein fortschritt also
das war der gedanke dass man die leute
nicht einfach nur aufbewahren kann
sondern dass es besserung gibt dass es
veränderungen gibt durch durch außen
einfluss
das ist ja auch so eine these von michel
foucault immer wieder gewesen dass das
anerkennen von krankheit aber eben nicht
als stigmatisierung auch dazu geführt
hat dass man leute eben unter umständen
ihnen therapien gegeben hat und nicht
einfach den pfarrer kommen lassen um den
teufel auszutreiben oder sie als
renitente personen irgendwie eingesperrt
hat mit einem gefängnisinsassen uns
vielleicht noch einmal den festzumachen
an einem beispiel nehmen wir auch das
was ihr eine mode diagnose nennen
nämlich adhs ich habe meinen alten
struwwelpeter mitgenommen ein buch von
18 44 ursprünglich da gibt es natürlich
diese berühmte geschichte vom
zappelphilipp der junge der sich nicht
benimmt am tisch und mit dem stuhl da
hin und her schwankt und schlussendlich
das tischtuch mitsamt den speisen
runterzieht und natürlich dann ein sehr
moralinsauer schluss die eltern haben
nämlich nichts zu essen und reinen der
zappelphilipp tester glaube ich unter
dem tischtuch gelandet nun gibt es
natürlich viele die sagen da sehen wir
es doch den zappelphilipp gab es immer
schon man hat natürlich noch kein
ritalin heute hat man ritalin böse
pharmaindustrie
er findet eine diagnose namen
adhs und schon können wir massenhaft
ritalin verabreichen das ist die anti
psychiatrische sehr böse geschichte was
sagen sie denn wenn wir jetzt wirklich
wissen wollen gibt des adhs ist schon
die frage falsch gestellt sie ist
insofern missverständlich vielleicht
gestellt als man sich fragen muss was
ist was meint man mit mit gibt es nicht
also wenn sie ihren biologischen marca
suchen den gibt es nicht obwohl man
danach forscht aber es gibt natürlich
verhaltensweisen wie ich jetzt beim
zappelphilipp die 1 1 krankenwagens
druck und nicht nur auf das kind sondern
für die ganze familie erzeugen die so
etwas wie behandlung erforderlich machen
bei jeder behandlung gibt es gibt auch
eine somatischen medizin der eisenmangel
zum beispiel da weiß man nie genau was
ist jetzt mode was ist vitamin d mangel
und so weiter also in dem sinne gibt es
etwas und man merkt zum beispiel auch
ritalin wirkt auch nicht in 100 prozent
aller fälle aber wie antidepressiva doch
in einem großen teil das wiederum
bestätigt die diagnose und das ist eben
adhs ist zum beispiel ein wenn man so
viel konstruiertes problem der schule
also wenn sie kinder immer nur
nach draußen in den wald schicken würden
kämen sie nie darauf dass adhs geben
könnte
genau deswegen sagen doch dann viele
krank sind nicht die kinder sondern
krank ist die gesellschaft das heißt die
pathologisierung wird einfach verschoben
eben das nur recht
ja ich glaube es hat niemand es hat
niemand da recht mal das geht ja immer
so davon aus dass es dass es im prinzip
nur das wirklich ist was auch ohne
gesellschaft besteht und das ist nun mal
halt halt nicht so also es wir leben
immer in vergesellschaftung 'nen man
kann sich durchaus vorstellen ob man
eine schule macht die zum beispiel
freundlicher für adhs-kinder ist also
die den leidensdruck nicht noch durch
den zwang zu still sitzen und so weiter
befördert aber das heißt nicht dass das
eine rein seien gesellschaftlich
konstruierte beziehungsweise von der
gesellschaft als einer kranken
gesellschaft hervorgebracht die symptome
ist würden sie denn auch nicht sagen
adhs hat zugenommen sondern würden sie
eher sagen dadurch dass man es benennen
kann sieht man jetzt auch er beides
glaube ich also ist es hat ja offenbar
als diagnose zugenommen was aber auch
damit zusammenhängt dass man sich mitte
diagnose entsprechende hilfen holen
das kann man auf der einen seite mag das
was katalogisieren das haben aber es
gibt zb möglichkeiten adhs kinder besser
zu betreuen dennoch ganz auffällig ist
beim autismus also autismus als diagnose
verschafft auch viele autisten und
autistin die möglichkeit sich
entsprechende hilfe zu holen und das ist
ja auch wieder zum beispiel wo wir sehen
es werden einerseits immer mehr menschen
als autistisch pathologisiert zugleich
gibt es auch die bewegung die
gesellschaft zu katalogisieren denken
sie zum beispiel an den philosophen
christoph türcke der rat so ein buch
geschrieben hat und der die auffassung
vertritt hier sind eine autistische
gesellschaft geworden
eine eine gesellschaft auch die eben
nicht mehr in der lage ist wirklich in
kontakt zu treten und so weiter also das
ist ja interessant dass man tatsächlich
immer dieses diese dieses gegeneinander
hartmann pathologisiert und video oder
die gesellschaft und das finde ich eben
jetzt grad vom türke mit der
autistischen gesellschaft finde ich ein
ganz grobes missverständnis man könnte
ja sogar sagen
gerade weil die gesellschaft
autistischer geworden ist ist sie viel
besser geeignet für autisten nicht das
ist ja häufig so eine
technikfeindlichkeit die in diesen
diagnosen von der autistischen
gesellschaft zustande kommt aber für
viele autisten und autistin ist zb die
erfindung des e mails des internets
überhaupt der sozialen medien ist eine
unglaubliche befreiung und entlastung
und meine these auch in dem buch ist
dass es da auf der technischen seite
eine entwicklung gibt die eines der
kernsymptome des vermeintlichen
kernsymptome der kommunikations
unfähigkeit zersetzt oder einfach
einfach auflöst also ich twittere mit
autisten und selbst mit nicht laut
sprachlichen autisten habe ich einen e
mail wechsel gehabt also dieses die sind
nur für sich und können sich nicht in
andere menschen einfühlen und so erweist
sich da wirklich als 19
das ist interessant dass ich eine
veränderung der welt kann auch ein
leiden kleiner werden lassen
im moment stellt man sich also ein
bisschen die frage werden wir alle
paranoid durch die pandemie
es gibt eine studie von der universität
bern die zeigen konnte dass menschen mit
einer wirklichen krankhaften paranoia
schon bei einer distanz von 24 metern
zwischen zwei personen stopp sagen und
den eindruck haben es kommt jemand zu
nahe
währenddessen menschen ohne krankhafte
paranoia bei 1,1 meter stopp sagen wenn
sie nicht verliebt sind jetzt haben wir
dieses 1,5 meter viele sogar zwei meter
wird uns das auch so verändern dass wir
parat
wieder werden oder kann man sagen diese
maßnahme hilft zb menschen mit paranoia
sich wohler zu fühlen und zum beispiel
sein also ich glaube das ist jetzt ein
bisschen schlechteres beispiel als jetzt
beim beim autismus also aber ja also es
mindestens könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass es eine mehr verständnis für so
etwas zum beispiel für eine bedrohung
durch nähe gibt also durch zuviel
unmittelbarkeit und darum eben geht mit
dieses ganze getue die smartphones
machen und autistisch dass das fing
schon mit dem anrufbeantworter und dem
fax an sein dass der niedergang der
schriftkultur und so das hat etwas
unglaublich betuliches und eben auch
nachweislich falsch ist und ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass diese pandemie
zustände ein vielleicht etwas milder
gegenüber solchen leuten mit mit ängsten
durch nähe verständlicher macht sie
erzählen dem buch auch von
wunderheilungen nämlich 1992 hat die whu
in ihrem diagnose manuel homosexualität
gestrichen aus krankheit als erstmal
muss ich sagen das hat mich unglaublich
schockiert dass das erst 19 92 war aber
interessant ist das was sie daraus
machen dass sie sagen so momentan noch
gestrichen hat wurden ganz viele leute
plötzlich aus nicht mehr krank angesehen
weil es diese diagnose sozusagen nicht
mehr gibt kann man sich diese art von
wunderheilung auch für andere
krankheiten vorstellen in zukunft
ich habe im moment keine andere im kopf
bei der es derartig radikal sein würde
also vielleicht noch das was jetzt
irgendwie transsexualität doch noch so
halb pathologisiert ist auch im dsm 5
wegen der jahreszeit noch die american
psychiatric association hat es immerhin
schon in den 70er jahren gemacht aber
sie ist dauernd jeanette heute an ja
immerhin was eben beim autismus denke
ich dass da
eben durch technische möglichkeiten eine
große veränderung einhergehen wird
autismus und homosexualität haben ja
auch insofern viel miteinander zu tun
als es auf beiden seiten eben diese
dieses etikett schippert also hatten
diese selbstvertretung auch der
betroffenen
es gibt auch ottenbreit also etwas
analog zur gay pride und was wird da
genau gemacht weil autisten sind jetzt
nicht diejenigen die gerne in einer
masse durch die straße ziehen
ich bin noch ich kenne nur die plakate
also ich bin da noch nie irgendwie
mitgelaufen aber es gibt auch workshops
das hatten hiking mal von erzählt
sommerlager für autisten
also es ist wirklich nicht so dass die
nicht mit anderen leuten zu tun haben
wollen sondern es sollte nicht so laut
sein es soll also es gibt besondere
anforderungen oder eine freundin die
selber programmiererin ist und
autistischen sohn hat aber sie ist nicht
autistisch der diese hacker kongress
jedes jahr
der ist voll von autisten und das ist
interessant diese frage nach der abo
karten schafft dass man sagen kann
tatsächlich das sr stark das
selbstbewusstsein zum glück in der lgbt
einem bewegung hat dazu geführt dass man
eben sache nennt pathologisiert hat und
bei den autismus artistin spricht man
heute ja eigentlich auch vom autismus
spektrum das heißt man geht davon aus
wir alle haben solche anteile beim nein
sind sie mehr ausgeprägt wie bei anderen
und insofern ist das einfach eine
variante die einen mögen es lieber so
die anderen mehr so und gerade weil in
der tech-branche
die ja sehr in ist im moment denken wir
an silicon valley und die ganze macht
der silicon valley hat könnte man
erwarten dass diese ad-hoc arten schafft
sozusagen zunehmend in zukunft jetzt
könnte ich mir auch denken und es gibt
ja es gibt diese nein es gibt
tatsächlich das sap zum beispiel eine
einstellungspolitik hat zehn prozent von
leuten auf dem autismus spektrum und
dazu gibt es dann den autisten wird eben
zehn prozent hh
also die eben davon ausgehen dass das
vermutlich 90 cent sind die da arbeiten
also ich denke da wird viel passieren
oder einer dieser autisten mit denen ich
da so e mail mäßig gechattet hat der
kann sich vorstellen zum beispiel als
avatar irgendwie so im virtuellen raum
von seinen sonstigen einschränkungen
befreit zu existieren also wenn ihr
ihrem buch titel nehmen normal gestört
verrückt gibt es für sie noch normal
gestört und verrückt oder sollten wir
überhaupt diesen termin nie aufhören
nein ich bin kein sprach bereinige also
ich glaube in manchen in manchen
situation kann man das durchaus sagen
mag ja sagen ach der so erfrischend
normal oder irgendwie die ist doch
verrückt oder ich würde erst an die hat
einen an der waffel oder also so
puristisch muss man das ja auch nicht
sagen
jegliche alltags begrifflichkeit von dem
von dem reinigen
aber es hilft einem natürlich schon wenn
man wenn man auch mit seinen eigenen
ticks marotten was immer sich ein
bisschen angefreundet hat irgendwie
milder mit den tics und den marotten
anderer zu sein und eben wenn jemand
darauf insistiert zum beispiel ein
eigenes büro zu haben und nicht in einem
großraumbüro mit dem namen oder wegen
bakterien phobie oder oder oder sonst
was dann finde ich muss es eben in der
arbeitswelt möglich sein dass der eben
tatsächlich sein eigenes büro bekommt
sie sagen auch dass sie eigentlich so
ganz ähnlich wie in der behinderung
forschung für inklusion plädieren und
sagen wir sollten so wie wir bereit sind
inklusion zu schaffen für menschen die
in einem rollstuhl sitzen sollten wir
auch bereit sein mit mehr war jahns zu
leben macht das leben ja eigentlich auch
bunter und interessanter wenn da
personen ebenso anders vielleicht sind
ist das auch etwas wovon sie sagen das
lernt man eigentlich auch schon bei
sigmund freud wenn wir noch einmal
zurückgehen zu ihnen
ja also dass da die psychoanalyse auch
eine große wandlung gemacht also ich
glaube in ihren anfängen war das sehr
viel mehr einfach eine versammlung von
irgendwelchen doch sehr besonderen
personen und daher ist eine große
toleranz solange die nur für die
psychoanalyse waren da hat hat der freut
gerne die leute noch noch genommen
das hat sich auch mit der zeit dann
immer zu einem normativen zimmer zu
immer normativen vorstellungen
verfestigt und die psychoanalytiker
waren zum beispiel die die sich
eigentlich bis zuletzt geweigert haben
homosexuelle
bewerber zur psychologischen ausbildung
zu lassen also da hat die psychoanalyse
einigen normierung strecke am stecken
obwohl sie eben von manchen
theoretischen ausgangslagen
prädestiniert gewesen wäre
die die fürsprecherin der homosexuellen
zu ich lerne von ihnen auf jeden fall in
diesem gespräch das ambivalenz eine
feine sache ist die sache ist eben nicht
schwarz-weiß sie wurden mal in einer
kolumne gefragt peter schneider wenn sie
eine stunde hätten mit sigmund freud
worüber würden sie mit ihm sprechen
wollen und sie haben zu antwort gegeben
sie würden auf jeden fall bessere
zigarren mitbringen wie diejenige die er
sich nun freut geraucht hat und sie
würden grosszügig von seinem eierlikör
kosten eine wirkliche antwort sind sie
schuldig geblieben
geben sie mir eine ja das hat damit zu
tun dass ich mit ihm gar nicht gerne
über psychoanalyse sprechen würde also
dass das ist so wenn man das eben
historisierend und von außen betrachtet
dann ist dann jemand vielleicht als
interviewpartner für wenn ich
irgendetwas erforschen wollte aber mit
ihm über psychoanalyse zu sprechen da
wäre er mir wahrscheinlich zu verbohrt
oder zu irgendwas also und worum soll es
dann gehen im gespräch das war jetzt
wirklich so fasst ernst gemeint also
gerne über über über zigarren eierlikör
das war jetzt der scherzhaft weil ich
mag kein würde irgendwas härteres mit
ihm mit ihm trinken
aber ich würde nicht mit ihm über den
ödipus komplex reden und ihm erklären
wollen warum ich das für eine
fehlkonstruktion halte sie ihn doch mal
treffen werden wir gerne dieses gespräch
ausstrahlung hätten sich noch hinkriegen
ich mache so eine versteckte kamera ein
sehr gut den herzlichen dank für das
gespräch
ja das anders zu sein nicht krank heißen
muss und gesund sind nicht dasselbe ist
wie normal
das sagt auch tom shakes dir der
wissenschaftler ist eine koryphäe auf
dem gebiet der behinderung forschung und
selber kleinwüchsig das gespräch mit ihm
verpasst haben wir zeigen es ihnen
nächste woche noch ein
und jetzt gleich steht ein modernes
märchen auf dem programm
die unglaubliche geschichte der
hoteladresse die vom mittellosen mädchen
aus memphis zur schweizer grand old lady
des jazz und blues aufgestiegen ist
träume sind manchmal eben doch keine
scheune bleiben sie gesund bis bald
[Musik]